if you were with all these yokels on
this junket here they come in with their
private jet what would be your first
question to the assembled my first
question would be we've seen the
tremendous amount of consolidation on
the distribution side of the media
equation with AT&T and DirecTV comcast
trying to get your time warner cable now
charge charter is getting it so how
about on the other side of the equation
with the media players the content
players the via comes the Disney's a
time when are we to see that we saw that
with time warner hbu Kison in Rupert and
it all fell apart right that was a
terrible transaction I have no idea how
that came about I'm going to blame the
investment bankers on that one but the
reality is a lot of these content
players really need to think about
getting bigger getting stronger relative
to their distribution partner and then
also how do they play in this digital
world that's probably the number one
issue I wouldn't go to do that but the
killer thing to me and this goes back to
goodwill in bad will is every headline
says this deal is accretive immediately
in your world can they say that if
they're playing with hugely valued stock
and they need a ton of cash to come up
with will these be those media friendly
accretive deals well you know the if you
look back to the 90s and early 2000s
that was not the case and the agree
accompanies destroyed value and one of
the reasons why the media stocks have
been so strong coming out of the
financial crisis is there haven't been
many deals they've been buying back
stock paying dividends that's been great
however i think you know given the
distribution consolidation you've seen i
think the pressure is on these companies
and investors are concerned the concern
about bad deals of the concern about
delusion help me with Chris basanti
right now a Grisanti Capital Management
he wants value he can't own anything in
your universe right well depends on how
you define value but you know in the
media space that's had a great run
really over the last seven or eight
years so the valuations are not at the
all-time highs but they are certainly
near the only thought that's really
cheap out there some of the cas's that
are really at risk in this digital world
such as the print media that the
newspaper stocks continued to
dramatically underperform and that's
where the value is what do you think
about kind of the Left behinds like the
Viacom's of the world would you go there
or would you pay up for a Disney a Time
Warner it's interesting i think the the
Viacom story you know investors are very
concerned about Viacom because they are
kind of a their cable networks are not
performing well which is really is
saying something because the cable
network business is a great business but
they have serious rating problems
they have serious concerns about their
children's demos and its vintage in
Brennan this is in Bloomberg
Businessweek the other week is what does
Sumner Redstone do is deal with his legs
wasn't it's so hard to get used to you
know not being able to pull the lever
and have the cash come out they could do
that for the entire 90s and until about
five or ten years ago yeah I think we
know one of the issues that you know for
the cable network business has been such
a good business for the media moguls out
there because advertising has been good
for the cable networks and Roy filia
fees go up ten percent every year Viacom
actually is having some issues because
some of their properties aren't as
strong as they want to cut to the chase
Olivia Sterns went out to Sun Valley for
the Idaho trout we know that or does
anything get done at these concepts
absolutely this deals get done here and
then maybe they don't get announced
during the week but deals get done at
this swindling begging to get on this
week ball you know I don't know I think
we're gonna see some of these cable
network companies maybe some of the
smaller cable network companies like
scripts like discovery like AMC you know
maybe see some of those you start
talking to each other and think about
hey where'd how do we stack up in this
new consolidated me media world do we
need to get bigger let's let's get me
get back to New York let's get our teams
together